the left went to places that we all know
are goofy they don't [__] know that
much so don't like make pronouncements
like you have a monopoly on the truth
why does that irritate you bill because
I don't like lying like you say we just
we don't want to pretend be a little
[__]
mysterious you know not everybody has to
know your opinion on every [__] issue
every kid you ever went to school with
on Facebook really just shut the [__] up
everybody just shut the [__]
up Bill it's great to see you again
thanks good to see you again thank you
so much for giving us your time listen
we'll get straight into it I always
think of you as as kind of the classical
Hollywood
liberal and in the last few years it may
be unfair characterization but in the
last few years you really broken with
the Orthodoxy here you made a joke on
your last show when you first came back
after rer strike uh kind of like about
not having any friends in Hollywood
only cuz he set me up for it but it was
perfect at that moment yeah it was funny
um I mean they left me I didn't leave
them I mean I I'm I'm the same that's
the what I'm always saying is like uh
the left went to places that we all know
are
goofy you know it's like I'm going to
I'm a comedian I'm going to make fun of
funny you know if you do I mean Obama
with a scorched Earth policy for comedy
you know which was great he wasn't a
buffoon but I good for the country bad
for ComEd yeah right but that's not the
case now with you know I mean identity
politics and victim culture and cancel
culture um hostility to free speech
these are all great
targets and worthy targets and I you
know was always willing to people people
I think don't remember how much I was
always willing to go after it on the
left but there just was less of it
Clinton wasn't an idiot either I mean he
was they tried to get him out of office
because of a [__] whose side was I
going to be
on
right so it you know things changed I
mean was it Jonathan height is he the
one who wrote the book and he his theory
I think he got it right it was like 2015
it was like gen Z ascends or something
and like we thought they were going to
backlash to the Millennials it just got
like 10 times worse it's like AI it was
exponential but the problem is Bill is
you look on comedy on TV and with a few
exceptions one in particular being your
show it's got really Toothless and and
that's a dangerous place well I've
gotten into trouble talking about this
subject before so I'm going to take a
pass on this question fair enough
because uh I'm friends with uh some of
these guys I certainly am an admirer of
some of these guys and their talents so
um you know I do think I will just say
your basic premise is
correct that there is one that doesn't
look anything like the others but that's
partly also because I'm not a celebrity
driven show I'm not having
on sitcom stars and just that's you know
what I'm doing here for brandom more no
we I think we have great people here but
we don't necessarily talk politics so
they're doing you know broad vvillian
shows I'm doing a political show I don't
have I hardly ever have a a celebrity I
mean show show business people yes
sometimes at the beginning of the show
we'll have an iconic you know Rod
Stewart how are you gonna say no to that
or something but it's you know that's
but most of the show is a panel with I
mean you were run it's got to be people
who are like super smart about what the
[__] is going going on in the world
that's not what the those guys so some
of it is just built in and then you know
yeah I mean
I have different takes on stuff and
um you know it's it's I tell
you there is a little too much like
uniformity
of opinion premise you know and and I
think that's one of the main problems
with Society at the moment bill is that
it does seem to be a uniformity of
opinion both on the left and the right
where we just put ourselves into tribes
and don't and are scared because we're
in tribes who actually go hang on I
don't agree with that yeah I I mean have
told this story before but like every
year I look at writer packets you know
like see who's out there and it's
like like this last the
lack of diversity of point of view I
mean it's one thing to write the
punchline but like what is your point of
view about a subject so I think what
they had to do was write about the you
know events of that week see if they can
write a monologue joke and I think it
was the week when uh Maloney took over
in Italy Italy yeah and it was like
uniformly she's a
fascist now I I know she the family has
fascist Roots I mean this came up
somewhere in conversation I said well
you know if we go back you know the
Democrats were the party of slavery
right you know so like everybody's got a
past so I don't know I said I don't
follow Italian politics closely but I'm
just not like I'm just like like off The
Geto gonna say this lady's a fascist
it's all onedimensional isn't it and
that's what like every writer wrote
based on the premise like she's a
fascist I was like okay um yeah that
that kind of stuff like it just gets in
The Ether that this is this is the
opinion to have and people are lazy they
don't really you know they want to seem
knowledgeable but not really know
anything nobody wants to do the reading
you know what I mean everybody wants to
be the college kid who turns up who
knows what they're talking about but no
one wants to go and read the books you
you see that nowhere more than what's
you know Israel whenever that now that
the war is on um you know they just do
not understand the history of this
conflict and you know that land and so
it's just screaming at each other over
you know identity politics Tri it's
tribalism just but there was another
thing too but which I think where a lot
of people you gained a lot of people's
respect not that you didn't have it
already for many people but there were a
lot of new people and you've talked
about it recently about how there are
conservatives now coming to see you live
yeah mixed audience is mixed which is a
great place to be great but the I think
part of the reason is that you really
made a break with what people thought
was your team over Co you really made a
break with them absolutely and other
things but you're right um um I was very
forthright I
didn't hold back with what I thought I
mean i' had already been CA cast as an
antivaxer but you know you it's almost
impossible to to deny that because it's
it's very much like the wi if she floats
she's guilty you know that thing like if
I deny if I say I'm not an anti well
that's what an antiva would say it's
just these people you can't argue with
people like that so but uh no my view
has always been pretty much the same I
always made a theme on real time from
the beginning 2003 I remember arguing
with Howard Dean who was a doctor in
2004 about medical you know just taking
that position of just I'm not all in
with Western medicine and I think
there's a a lot of corruption and I
think there's just a lot we don't know
those are my two big ones is like is
there corruption yes we just found out
with the Sackler family for example the
people who make uh what was it oxy
conton and I think they got find 8
billion I mean that's you know we so
it's we know they're capable of being
corrupt you know for purposely hooking
people on their hillbilly her heroin you
know so we we know they're capable of it
but even when they're not trying to be
corrupt I mean I don't think they were
trying to make a vaccine that then
didn't prevent you from getting it they
of course wanted that to be the result
they came up with a vaccine I think that
uh is very appropriate for people who
are not in good health and probably if
you have it you you would your life was
saved by something that could have
killed you but I don't fit that profile
so I shouldn't have had that yeah I
didn't that's not why you spoke up about
it because you just felt he was a
one-size fits all solu correct it's not
scientific it's not even it shouldn't
even be a political issue should be a
medical issue it's just medical all of
this
stuff
so yeah I mean I'm I've I've certainly
lost plenty of people but I those kind
of people were never really going to be
completely happy with me and they never
were completely happy with me you know
they didn't like me about religion stuff
you know but Bill isn't the problem as
well and you've just alluded to it
actually is you said politics got
involved now all three of us sitting
here yeah with Co but with everything
politics gets involved now with
everything every decision you make it
just see a perfect example of this
constant and I were in Amsterdam and we
saw you know one of these you know
flamethrowers of flame jugglers whatever
it it's called and before he started his
act a street performer a street
performer that's it before he started
his act he gave a 5 minute political
lecture about the Dutch right-wing
government and I'm like and then he
started juggling
balls that's perfect you just go even
with someone like this I still get
politics rammed down my throat I mean
that's a problem isn't it that is
certainly one of the problems it's uh a
theme also in my standup act now at the
end when I'm uh talking about how we we
can't go the
marjerie Taylor green we need a national
divorce route we can't we cannot get
divorced even if we want to it's just
not practical it's stupid so we have to
learn to yes get along and just live
side by side with [__] you can't
stand and you
know and part of that is just not always
talking about politics we we never used
to do that when when I was a kid parents
and saw their friends saw them with
their friends and it was almost
considered impolite yeah politics and
religion so you didn't know that you
hated this guy you know right you didn't
you know he was just your neighbor and
you could and you got they got along
great and you know don't share
everything would be one of my big pieces
of advice be a little [__]
mysterious you know not everybody has to
know your opinion on every [__] issue
every kid you ever went to school with
on Facebook really they have to know
what you think about Ivor
mton just shut the [__] up everybody
just shut the [__] up about politics 247
and otherwise we're always going to be
this CU is anybody ever convinced of
anything yeah I mean well we can't even
we can't even agree what men and women
are anymore so if we can't agree with
that about that then how are we going to
agree on something like Israel which is
a very very serious complex issue
well you can tell the women from the men
in my
hot I don't know where I don't know what
you're doing
man well we're more Progressive not a
problem no I know I mean that's I mean
it's easy to say that's of course we do
but um yeah I mean that's one of those
issues that to me it's always like if we
weren't crazy and completely political
like you said
and always partisan about everything we
could just agree
okay some people are trans their their
their gender thoughts don't match with
their gender equipment of
course and also some of it's trendy but
nobody wants to like get on that
obviously
true Center position I'm not saying it
just because it's taking from both sides
because it's actually true some of it is
trendy and it's also a real thing that
should be
protected really nobody could like run
on that kind of [__] there's no nobody
out there who could like [__] just
take all the issues and kind of do that
the Border you know like yes we need to
just not have a on size fits all and
also we're not going to bomb
them it's like everyone just go to
what's nuttier isn't it weird like it's
either like trans women or women doesn't
matter if they have a penis or on the
other hand is like women need to go back
in the kitchen is isn't there some kind
of Middle Ground there I I just feel
like we talk about these issues on this
kind of show and all over the news and
ever so much and it's just a very small
not that they shouldn't be respected but
it's just a very
small it's it reminds me of Alward books
one said like TV it's like every show is
about a private detective if you look
you look in the phone
book there's only two real private
detectives I know what you mean and I
get frustrated talking about some of the
stuff cuz a lot of it isn't that
interesting it really isn't a lot of
these things the trans thing and all
this other stuff because as you said we
all know what the [__] truth is right
and all of these political posturing
positions are uh are insane however I do
think that you know the idea of Truth is
really important very and so what
bothers me is people making me pretend
right that things that that are
blatantly false right are not like the
emperor is naked and he's got his dick
out no you said it very well making me
pretend that's what like a lot of the
people who watch shows like yours and
mine mhm uh like about what we do is
it's just that protestation don't make
me pretend like there's just a lot of
pretending because the far-left woke
people are so intimidating they're
they're they they have crazy stupid
ideas about a lot of stuff but they're
really good at media and people are just
intimidated that the Mean Girls of
Twitter will destroy you so you can just
be really out there with whatever you
say woke wise and even the people who
know better will
just that's going to let that one pass
too dangerous you
know and so that's how you get a lot of
the stuff that like you say we just we
don't want to pretend no I I mean I
don't want to pretend that I mean
women uh and men in sports are
anything comparable I mean if if the
worst NBA team played the best WNBA team
the score would be a million to zero
yeah that's no insult to women is just
the way it is yeah and to make me
pretend why does that irritate you bill
because I don't like lying well see I
just don't you can I I have tons of
friends on both sides even far woke far
Trump whatever as long as you're sincere
but don't [__] lie to me yeah and and
you know the other thing as well bill
that I I feel it a lot is just [__]
leave me alone you know we and that I
got that more than ever with coid where
it just felt that it just it was almost
a reason for the government to stick
their little finger into your life and
also incentivize other people to do it
as well well I think the I think a lot
of people in government and the medical
community
it's they sincerely believe they're
doing the right thing they're you know
safetyism
they
they see safety which is the short-term
good of lockdowns and masks and mandates
and all that kind of stuff I mean first
of all they they may not be right about
the efficacy of the vaccine but as far
as
safety they think they're doing the
right thing but they're but they're in
the system you know it's just it's that
kind of thing where do you really know
you're you slowly just fall into the
group think of okay this is how we
handle the problem lockdown
vaccine um not that
vaccines you know are to me a a tool
that I'm very glad we have but I should
get to pick whether I want or not based
on the pathogen and my
situation and there could be something
that comes along where I would be the
first
online vaccines generally work yeah you
know Bill I want to come back to this
conversation about lion because it's
interest interesting to me I really
respect your work as U one of reasons is
I've always been more interested in
satire than comedy and you at your best
I think are satirical in that you are
talking about political issues you're
making fun of both sides very often uh
and I think that really is the job of
people like you is is to to point out
where the the the hypocrisies are where
the lack of Truth is ETC but not many
people are now doing that with comedy of
fields like well they do it on one side
they but they they pause when it com
comes down to saying something that's
going to make their completely liberal
audience
disapprove you know they take the path
of least
resistance when it comes to stuff on the
left that is worthy of making fun
of because the audience doesn't want to
hear
that
um or they really believe it I mean I
but they it's more by Omission you know
um I mean they'll do Biden jokes about
his age or something like that which is
fairly anod but you never
really
um are in question about what the take
you know what the the point of view
is that's the that's the that's the
point the point of view yeah it's so
important and it's so important that the
point of view is not boring that the
point of view is not the same as
everybody else's point of view my friend
calls it let me guess
politics brilliant and it let me guess
and and it's always and um I'm not ever
let me guess that's so uninteresting is
and they just won't like I remember
there was this
um about two years ago a shooter some
nut mass shooting in I think Atlanta and
he he killed a bunch of Asian people
because they ran m parlers do you
remember this case yes
okay okay
and I read the stories and it was clear
by the end of the week and I said on the
air it it's not what the media is saying
that it was he wasn't mad at Asians he
was mad at people who were jerking him
off because he was a Christian everybody
in his life said it the FBI said it and
the other people would not move off this
narrative
and that's the difference between truth
and
narrative it's like the narrative is you
know it's part of this giant anti-asian
crime wave um and I'm sure there
is horrific crimes that are you know
committed against Asians as they are
against other peoples and we should stop
them all but this was not one of
them they just you know they just shove
this [__]
thing you know hold it just F get
in get the [__] it's like closing a suit
case and they and I I hate that [__] I
think we all do because what it puts us
in bill is in a really dangerous
position where we stop believing what
we've been told in the news and
newspapers and once that happens you
you're in like I said you're in a really
dangerous situation because people go
this is is all fake this is all fake so
when the next pandemic comes along for
example as it will do or there's some
other type of emergency you're just
going to get whole sves of people going
I don't believe any of this well the CDC
has already lost a lot of credibility I
mean they I think they all did
when you know people Liv through it so
they remember oh yeah I remember washing
the mail for six months for no [__]
reason you know washing the mail really
so again my big theme they don't [__]
know that much so don't like make
pronouncements like you have a monopoly
on the truth that's it's so anti-science
that people like follow the
science can be so
anti-science that's so true yeah that's
so true and Bill did you see this coming
because I remember all oh no
not he was there he was there in ch in
the lab just they did not see it coming
no I don't mean this I mean the culture
I mean where we are now as a society no
because but I do remember your standup
from way back when talking about how we
now prioritize feelings over truth and
all this stuff no I mean my first show
was called Politically Incorrect that
was 30 years ago right I definitely
recognized it a political correctness
which I always I was asked a lot because
I named the show that it was like what
does that mean to you you know the
elevation of sensitivity over truth I
think was one of my big
answers um and just the opposite of you
know when someone is political it means
they're full of [__] usually you know
I's very political about it Politically
Incorrect was let's just say what it is
so I did see that it was a problem 30
years ago yeah it just got worse I mean
I tried to put a stake in its heart and
obviously
especially with the internet but also
the generations I mean we just keep
making each generation is more fragile
if you can believe it they said that
about my generation from the World War
II people like these Boomer kids are so
spoiled why they we don't have we don't
even beat them every night you
know when I think of like
how idolic I think my childhood was but
also like so different than kids today
and not coddled nearly as much no but
you know what I was thinking about
political correctness 30 years ago it
wasn't really the same people doing it
like my heroes growing up it was George
Carlin and Bill Hicks and these people
would and you were also talking about
religion because it was the Christian
right right who wanted to shut people
like you down oh yeah they wanted you
not to be able to joke about religion no
that's and and now it isn't them really
leading the charge I know they exist I
know they're out there I know they don't
like you joking about religion but
they're not the driving force behind
political correctness in 2023 would you
AG no of course
that's again you're that's my [__]
defense when people are like well you've
changed no they changed like I could
every issue I could do that with we're
like this is old school liberal and this
is woke like I noticed we are have
complet complely given up on the idea
that the thing to do if you're
overweight is diet and exercise which
was like Bedrock I mean it was Michelle
Obama Michelle Obama was we loved her
for that she perfect message first lady
now that's like I mean you never read in
the New York Times that like the no no
no it's just a fact we don't we don't
know really why I mean they they're kind
of on that page but we have
OIC you know and you know once again
it's a pharmaceutical solution I'm not
saying that's a giant conspiracy I'm
saying drug makers are not in the
business of healing Humanity they're in
the business of selling drugs they do it
by healing Humanity a lot I mean I'm I'm
glad we have pharmaceutical companies I
mean we need their [__] sometimes and
they've done a lot of great things but
they want to sell drugs do you
think yeah you know they're if they have
one that can make you lose weight
they'll sell it to you and they're not
are they sure about side effects or what
the real health for repercussion I think
we we're kind of like I mean they don't
know why it works you know that no they
have no idea how why it
works they know that it works not why
not a clue so wouldn't that give you
pause it would do yeah okay so again
like this is where liberalism was 10
years ago and this is where it is
now Bill do you think sometimes the
problem is is what every time that we
come to America it's that's the
problem that is a problem come to
America but it's a it's a culture built
around consumerism and ease making
everything as easy as possible and
comfort so is yours yeah I'm not well
have you ever experienced our customer
service it's not about
is Junior I
mean but do you see what I
mean about England no about the US is
that everything is about making things
as easy as possible and if you do that
yeah but I think that's a lot of
countries now because I mean England
became America yeah we import your I
mean I remember being in England first
time in the 80s and it was very
different yeah I'm very different how so
well first of all London was like all
white yeah y it was you know so can we
just celebrate that victory that we made
a place more diverse and not you
know you never get a pat on the back the
people who like achieve I feel like in
that area there's only like there's more
to do of course there's more to
do but can we just get a little hey I
think I I think I read Andrew Sullivan's
column like London went from
like uh
36% so like 86% people of color or
something like that now maybe that's too
high but some something like a 50 like a
50 point swing 50 points in two
generations three generations okay
that's progress I I'm not a bad person
to like clap for
Progress U but but that is but that is
an issue that is a real issue bill when
people because people never want to
admit how when things are going well and
if you only start going oh everything's
terrible then you start convincing
everybody else that everything's
terrible when it's not I mean you say
people I feel like this is something
that divides the two parties I feel like
Republicans are too like peppy about
America and very sentimental about
America um and think things are better
you know like racially I think they're
they're raci they're they in denial
about racism which is still a thing MH
and the left is like overexaggerating it
MH you know they're so down on
America and it's by the way something
immigrants don't like about the left I I
hate that about them I know I know you
do that you people who work so hard to
get here and then all you do is what a
[__] all it is and also it's just again
factually wrong because we we we can
know what's going on in other countries
and again these people who do not know
things like this but it does not in the
least deter them from tweeting and
talking and saying things and I mean
I've seen these funny videos where they
you know man on the street with you know
20-year-old kids and like I'd like to
live anywhere but here really what do
you know about
Somalia what do you know about uh
Karachi Pakistan is that would that you
know I mean uh I see this porn
star is uh was being very Pro Palestine
khif yeah and uh try practicing porn in
Gaza would be my that que for Palestine
yeah the yeah brilliant was that on a
t-shirt it was it was a flag there were
there was a bunch of people holding up a
flags and qu for palestin I think I've
seen that on a t-shirt yeah and
uh yeah try walking down the street with
that in uh I could name a lot of places
in the world do you think we're victims
of our own success in the west so
comfortable so wealthy so genuine I mean
Francis makes this point it's a great
point the the biggest privilege any of
us enjoy is first world privilege that's
the privilege yeah I say very similar
things about the the the people who just
go on and on about
privilege um don't realize that they're
always being propped up by the privilege
of
being
impractical loose thinking and you're
just like head in the clouds which is a
great privilege to be right but that's
ironic it
is we'll be back with our guest in a
minute but first we want to take a
moment to talk about our partners GI and
go give and go is a leading crowdfunding
website where thousands of people around
the world raise funds for business
ventures medical expenses personal needs
nonprofits churches and funeral costs on
giv and go you can raise money for
whatever you need we've met the people
at GI and go and we can tell you that
they're absolutely aligned with
trigonometry on our approach to free
speech they don't just talk the talk
they walk the walk unlike other big tech
companies they like us believe that with
openness and honesty will create more
understanding and ultimately more
Harmony in the world gifs and go is
absolutely free to use with other
crowdfunding sites you'll pay between 5
and 10% of the money you raise giv and
go charge no money at all to use their
platform they believe you should be able
to keep all the money you raise on giv
and go you can choose to raise funds for
short or long-term campaigns whether
you're in the USA UK Australia or
anywhere in the world GI and go supports
freedom of speech they won't cave to the
Mob and that's why we proud to partner
with them starting a campaign on giveen
go is easy and intuitive go to gien
go.com today start raising money for
whatever's important to you and support
the people who support Freedom now back
to the
interview do are you hopeful for America
Bill well I ain't going anywhere so yeah
and I mean
Kar what about madish I am amazed a
little
I am amazed a little bit that we take
man this country we we take a lick and
we keep we keep on [__] ticking yeah
really we keep we keep on ticking I mean
I thought the pandemic with that kind of
spending and keeping people home would
take us down no
Trump I can't believe we survived Trump
are you guys trumpers no no however will
ask you this because it's interesting to
me I did not like him his personality is
obnoxious I didn't like it among other
things you know this is what I want to
ask you right because I don't know too
much enough about American politics to
say whether his policies were good for I
don't honestly please I don't why do why
are you suddenly pleading ignorance on
this you this is what you do no hold on
well let's break it down right so was
his policy on the board
better or worse than Joe Biden looks
like it's the same now Biden's building
the wall at least he was trying right I
mean Biden's just letting people in like
crazy yeah I mean I don't I never
thought a wall was a terribly
practical solution because people have
thought of it before and there's just a
lot of like things you obviously he
couldn't get through obviously he
couldn't get it through so that's how
hard it is you know it's private land or
you just can't build a UNP
border look if the Republicans were
serious about wanting to stop
immigration what they would do was they
would crack down on the hiring but they
don't want to because they want the
cheap labor so they want to pretend that
they are stopping people from coming in
and they don't like people coming in but
they like it drives down wages and they
could do that you could you could crack
down on that end of it okay but that
doesn't happen nobody's going through
the kitchen and yelling
mtion from my perspective it doesn't
seem like Biden is better than Trump on
that when I look at the international
situation I mean the the American
respect for America is breaking down
around the world that's why you see all
these conflict they say that every
year Well we see more conflicts every
year are you kidding we're [__]
kicking ass we came back better from the
pandemic economically than any other big
boy
country I don't know how we do it but
but if you look at like the stock market
from like 1990 to now like if you had
your money in American stocks like three
four times better than anywhere else I'm
talking about it matters of course it
matters no you're right I mean the
dollar is nobody's really even
pretending that they could like replace
the dollar or would want to I mean with
our kind of debt I I mean at some point
is some of this going to come crashing
down it absolutely
could but I don't know what like we just
keep on ticking I just I I I I'm I'm
surprised that with all the [__] going
on but America is a great country but
what I'm trying to get out with you it
is it is a great country I'm not Mr Rah
I'm just saying these are the facts the
biggest like five biggest tech companies
in the world I think are all American I
mean yeah now China has um you know some
things that we don't but our military is
still like there's nobody even close I'm
I couldn't agree with you more I'm just
saying so I'm Team America I am no this
isn't about bragging about America this
is just factually like where we are
let's not be let's not have the wrong
idea in our head about what our exact
place in the world is um we're we're
we're taking on water but for some
reason we're not sinking I'm just trying
to get to the question which is you said
something which is very interesting to
me you're a smart guy you're a Nuance
thinker but you said we survive Trump
and that surprised totally what is it
about you kidding so so give people cuz
he's crazy first of all he's stupid and
he's crazy I always stupid bill so he
can't be he thought Frederick Douglas
was alive are you kidding he yes he's
stupid he has a a
hitlerian uh ability to move
crowds yeah often with the same sort of
thoughts about you're cheated and the
soil and you know all this [__]
obviously he never went where Hitler
went he's I'm not comparing him with
Hitler in that way but just as a
insane but that also made him genius
politician okay who can move people and
just owns [__] people just like owns
them MH and that's his talent but is he
stupid yes and he's [__] crazy but
but on those two things in Congress that
you've just said that he's a politician
of genius and he's stupid politician
yeah of
Genius butl yes yeah but the only genius
he is politically he's a genius yeah
polit because he doesn't even think
about it he just comes out of his ID and
that works for people they even though
he's the most full of [__] guy he also
is like the most honest mhm like when he
says [__] hole countries like lots of
immigrants are like yeah that's exactly
where I came from why do you think I
[__] walked a th000 miles to get here
because I was in a [__] hole and this
guy doesn't mince words and because he
almost yeah he can't help himself he he
reveals
himself that's it's it's Insanity
photographs what can I tell you so he's
he's
mesmerizing to the media too M um so he
gets all that coverage but yes am I
surprised we survived a and we really
haven't yet because he's still hasn't
conceded that election that's why I'm
asking just the just the idea of a guy
who doesn't concedes elections okay you
guys should like stop worrying about all
these other little that's it that's the
ball game if the guy doesn't concede
elections did Hillary concede elections
of course Hillary can see she said he's
an illegitimate president when did she
say that she said that in 2016 she said
he knows he is an illegitimate president
I believe he knows he's an illegitimate
president he knows he knows that there
were a bunch of different reasons why
the election turned out the way it did
and I take responsibility for those
parts of it that I should and so I know
that he knows that this wasn't on the
level I don't know that we'll ever know
everything that happened but clearly we
know a lot and are learning more every
day and history will probably sort it
all out so of course he's obsessed with
me and I believe that it's a guilty
conscience in so much as he has a
conscience after the election yeah
Russia collusion what was that if not
denying the election they made up a
story which was a hoax well it wasn't a
Hox yeah it was it wasn't true what
wasn't true what part of the Russia
collusion the idea that there was
collusion with Russia the idea there was
absolute collusion with Russia is that
why he won the election do you think
partly it was a very close election yeah
you don't think Russia could sway like
what 77,000 votes in three states of
course they could and they did partly
through social media partly for their
propaganda there and what they were
trying to do there which was very
successful cost about
$100,000 and then I mean Trump's
campaign manager was trading campaign
data with a gr gr I think what Trump was
saying is completely wrong I agree but
but there was Democrats also denied the
election in 2016 they
did okay I mean maybe one time Hillary
said something like that she you ask her
today this is not an issue for the
Democrats you're making a ridiculously
false you think con comparison of course
Democrats are not the ones who deny
elections Hillary got up there in her
[__] purple suit and said um we lost
Al Gore did it took won for the [__]
team in 2000 agreed it's it's just a
ridiculous false
um false comparison yeah okay yeah
so looking at but looking at Trump and
let's look at on a global scale like we
were talking about before if you look at
what with Biden when he's come to power
there has been the Russian invasion of
Ukraine there's been the disastrous
withdrawal from
Afghanistan and you've also as well got
build now this situ flaring up and some
people would say the argument that they
put forward is this is all happening
because Biden is a weak leader people
have seen that and are using that
opportunity to them pursue their own
ends well you know whenever I hear
something like um the disastrous
withdrawal from Afghanistan it's just
like oh rightwing talking point not that
it's not true it is true but it's like
you really give a [__] I mean should
they have handled it better Absol
absolutely I'm not sure America ever
handles anything well we're just a [__]
up country now in a lot of ways I'm I
just I don't know if any president under
any conditions but this one finally said
let's get the [__] out of here this is a
crazy thing to be here forever we're
here 20 years we just got to go I mean
it it's probably going to be shitty no
matter how we do it no you know with if
Mitt Romney was President would it have
gone better yeah I bet it would because
Mitt Romney was like much more of a
detail you know he tried to cast himself
as
a conservative real hard right guy when
he ran he was a manager of detail he was
a Mormon couldn't be a nicer guy could
he yeah he might have been the guy who
like stayed up looking over the plans
and the data at 4 in the morning you
know Clinton was that guy you know
people who really like government want
to make it work well B's not that guy
yeah he didn't do that with Afghanistan
but it's like G you know just so
reflexive here's something we can hate
about this guy who we want to talk bad
about I'm not on that page that's a
little too like just one-sided for me he
you know do I love everything with Joe
Biden absolutely not I just last week I
called for him to not run again Ruth
Bader Biden I
would you think he's too old I think the
country does and that's all that matters
and he will not win he'll look terrible
in the debates and Trump will win and
that will be a disaster and there should
be no discussion after he does not
concede elections not I mean yes Stacy
Abrams also said something about I mean
this is like yes you can always make
some case on the other side it has
nothing to do with a guy who was
president never
advertised he was never going to concede
an
election didn't still doesn't we'll do
it
again that's nothing is nothing is on
that level if you if that is where you
are I don't care what his [__] policy
on Turkmenistan
is you're just qualified democracy
relies on loses consent correct it's
what we have over the other countries
that so many other countries in the
world can't get that one thing right
yeah like they the the you know the old
Soviet days used to always see
like they would check like who was
standing closest to the coffin you know
like and that was usually the guy who
knocked off the guy before him and or
who is going to be next and you know it
wasn't done through
a system mhm it was like who's just
going to
like was Survivor yeah you know and then
it was oh RF okay and then he got to be
and that's not the way we did it and
this guy wants to bring that to here
yeah that doesn't work do you think one
of the distinctions as well is what
happened on January the 6th right
because whatever the Democrats may have
said that never happened that it was
just a different level you know physical
people physically going into the capital
and and I I mean it's not what Trump
said on that day it wasn't like he got
up there and said go and take over the
capital
kind of not totally it was that up until
that moment he still hadn't conceded
yeah it was the whole it's not one
moment it was like his whole view that
he was telling his people that this and
you know when you do this against what
Republican vote counters were telling
him Jesus I mean that's bending over
backwards yeah the even the Republicans
told him his own people and the the
decent people who are Republicans in
many states all these states were
lawsuits were you know lots this was
laugh out of court like 60 times or
something and they still tried to Pedal
that bull that is just unacceptable
don't don't come to me with like and
Trump did
this
no that's that's fair enough Bill and do
you think in 2024 do you think he's
going to do you think he's going to win
the nomination do you think he's going
to go the whole way that's there's no
doubt it would be the
nominee and he very well could could win
and then we would be I believe
governed by him under house arrest at
maralago that's probably where he will
be and he will he will run the country
from maral Lago they will never put him
in jail but he will be convicted at
least in one of these trials and then he
will
be I mean you know it'll be like in Good
Fellas where they smoke smuggle in a
salami
got they're wearing track suits I mean
not going to be some Jeffrey Epstein
jail cell this no he'll probably house
arrest at Maro that is where the I mean
that's the final and then I AI takes
over Network I don't I honestly with AI
don't think we we'll make it through the
decade you've been reading about that I
got Triston hris on real time Friday and
and we're going to talk about and I have
been reading about it and it's super
frightening but yeah I got to go back to
my day job Bill what a pleasure it's
been great such a pleasure I appreciate
you guys coming in I love what you do I
feel like uh this Stern talking to
tonight was well in
order I hope to see it reflected in your
show in the future all right best of
luck
[Music]